Her low freak bitches.
Have you eaten polar bear?
Oh,
absolutely.
What does polar bread tastes like?
You know what I've eaten at?
It's up in the Arctic with the annual it.
And so they,
they boil everything.
It's a boiled and,
and uh,
it's funny you put salt,
lick the brisket.
It normally where we need the backstraps,
you know,
that'd be the first choice or 10 wines,
the Inuit nod,
it's the brisket because when you boil it,
that's where you've got
this great textures,
you know,
that they're crunchy.
Uh,
I mean,
I don't even know what you'd call
a cartilage and connective tissue.
There's not just meat and fat.
So that's the,
you know,
it was,
it was a delicacy.
I would rate it right up there with
the best of the meat I've ever had now
Healy.
Oh,
absolutely.
But boiled with salt and being
very hungry out on the ice.
You know,
you spent 20 days out in the
ice with annual it on a dog.
Sledger you're hungry.
He,
you know,
they kill a barrier unit near,
it's like the best finest Coby
beef and downtown New York City.
Is it relative to where you're at
and the struggle that your enemy,
if you had it in La,
if I took it to a restaurant down the
street and hard to say because there is no
restaurant serves it,
so it's hard to,
hard to take it out of
that context and say,
is it the best meat?
Now here,
I don't know.
I mean while cheap,
same thing.
You're on a mountain and you've been
backpacking for 10 days carrying 50 to 70
pounds on your back and you finally get
you around and run down to below Alpine
and find some little sticks and make
a fire and roast the ribs on it.
I defy anybody to tell me there's a
better piece of meat in this world that
tastes better than that wild sheep
on a mountain after a sheep hunt.
But would it be that good if I was
downtown New York City or here in la?
You know,
I don't know because you,
you just can't do it.
It doesn't exist.
One of the best meals
I've ever had in my life.
We shot a mule deer,
that deer right there in Montana.
And uh,
we,
we ate the liver and
the heart of that night.
It was insane.
It was so delicious.
That's the camp fire and just cooked it
over oil with a little salt and pepper.
And we were just moaning
with delight like an orgy.
Anyone that doesn't hunt,
that isn't out there can
never know what we're,
what,
what you're describing.
I know it.
I've had the same thing and I've had,
you know,
Moose liver and name it,
name it,
you know,
antelope all around the world.
We've had the same thing.
It's the best of the best.
It's the perfect,
I think it's because that's who we are.
That's who we are.
We're,
we're not the,
the fancy restaurant,
you know,
thousand dollar bottles of wine and whole
whole wait cuisine is not what we are.
We're,
we're just,
we're just that we eat
wild game cooked on a fire.
That's the truth.
We can ever be.
That's the truest,
most natural flavor and,
and eating that we could ever do.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
It's interesting.
I,
I don't have it gets stuck in your head,
but I don't know either.
Good.
But it,
it seems like a very likely scenario.
I mean,
the,
the brain's functional and it's
the most traumatic experience ever.
And you don't have any context.
Don't have any language.
You don't have any knowledge
of why you're there.
No one's explained what's going to happen.
All of a sudden you're born,
that's gotta be unbelievably traumatic.
You've been hearing this,
right?
Oh,
hold on.
Top of that.
Add circumcision.
And how about the apple?
Slice your fucking Dick with a razor.
Welcome home.
Why you cut his dick?
Wyatt,
welcome to Earth.
We're just going to let the kid be clean.
What about soap?
Anybody ever?
Everybody we're talking about
soap to cut his fucking Dick.
Wow.
Hit screamings.
Dick's on fire.
Screaming.
Just came out of a pussy.
Dixon actually,
how long do they wait
for the circumstances?
They probably don't do it right away,
but they definitely stick
you with needles right away.
They vaccinate you like instantly.
We're worried about disease.
Fucking shove needles right
into that baby's body.
Start pumping chemicals.
Do you ever do a home birth?
Fuck No.
What am I living in a cave.
What am I on a fucking farm somewhere
and a Clint Eastwood movie about the 18
hundreds to fuck out of here.
Sally.
I don't think she's going to make it.
Try your hardest.
That's how the whole damn blue rosary,
every western birth movie,
it's like they act.
If you get the water bucket there in time,
that baby will survive.
It fixed me a bucket of water.
Yeah.
Fucking a water.
Went some cloths and clean clauses.
Walter,
what is the bucket of water?
Dh?
It like baby's turned around.
I'm gonna have to go in there.
He goes anywhere.
It's farmer hands and ruins.
Your wife's pussy shoves his gigantic
gorilla like farmer hands into that pussy
and spins it around.
He's the only guy knows how to do
it cause he's done it with calves.
We've got a breach crab.
Alrighty.
Rolls his sleeves up to his
elbow and just fucking lubes.
The whole thing,
just launches it in there and spins around
your kid fingernails just under half.
Good fucking country doctor.
Just fucking go for shit.
Monkey bullshit.
He wiped his ass with his
fingernails better 12th every yet.
It just took a giant farmer,
doctor crap and your in your,
in your outhouse and he's reaching into
your wife's Plessy and out gotta have
strangled the [inaudible]
mountain nurse baby.
And then he'd do a
smack it to make it cry.
Yeah.
And the poor thing,
it's just like,
what happened?
What happened?
Why?
And that's what pushed us to
go out and look at this like,
so we,
we went to the West Bank and hung
out with this comedy satire troop.
Whoa.
Who has a television show that it's,
it's once a week,
but during Ramadan it's
every single night for 30.
And so,
whoa.
Um,
yeah.
And so like we hung out with these folks,
like,
so these are people who are there
living in the West Bank and they're
criticizing everyone.
So they're criticizing the Palestinians,
Israel,
the Israelis,
the Americans,
Brock,
um,
wow.
Uh,
you know,
like Oh,
Sama and Obama in the same sketch,
right?
Like the,
you know,
these guys are doing really cutting
edge stuff in this place that there,
there aren't comedy clubs like your,
the way that you get professional comedy,
there's like two shows on Palestinian
national television or you need to find it
broadcast from Egypt or from
Jordan or I'm not sure Jordan,
because evidently the Jordans
aren't terribly funny.
Jordanis aren't very funny.
But the Egyptians are like rural areas,
Jordanians or funny,
that Guy Right now listening.
It's fucking pissed.
There is a no,
we talked to these guys and they're like,
oh yeah,
there's a,
um,
there's like a hierarchy of comedy in
the Middle East and according to them the
Palestinians are about the middle.
The Egyptians are hilarious really.
And the Jordanians evidently are
like the most serious or Hawaii.
They're very funny.
Yes.
What do you attribute that to?
I can't remember.
I don't know.
Uh,
I was,
Joel was here.
He remembers everything.
He cause he writes it all down.
But uh,
yeah,
there's like a long history of,
uh,
of,
of Egyptian comedy.
Ha.
Very funny people.
What about,
uh,
the Israelis do they factor in there?
Yeah.
So,
so what was really fascinating was that,
um,
so we,
you know,
you have kind of the stereotype of the,
of the,
the funny Jewish person,
right?
Very self deprecating.
Um,
but you don't find that style
of comedy in Israel as much.
The Israeli,
um,
comedy is a lot more aggressive.
Like it's the,
it's the comedy of the victor not of the,
of the victim.
Oh.
How's,
and so we found this weird reversal where
the Palestinians were much more sort
of self deprecating and their
comedy was much more Jewish in,
in the American sense than you
would have necessarily expected.
So it was really,
I was really fascinating.
Okay.